we probably heard the story this week
about a New York City High School who
booted its students for a day they went
to remote learning because a high school
principal uh named jod Cohen at James
Madison High School uh brought in
illegal immigrants for an overnight stay
she says due to flooding in in heavy
torrential rain in in New York City says
on Tuesday well she's received a lot of
push back she's received a lot of uh
backlash in response to that decision
booting a American students in favor of
uh illegal immigrants she said the
following on a zoom call she said please
know that I put your kids first I do
what I do because I care about children
and I find it offensive that people are
putting things on that chat I don't
understand how people who never come on
a zoom like this could take an
opportunity like this evening to throw
mud this is for one night one
night so she turns the tables and claims
she is offended yeah
but also the the the illegal migrants
are staying on the football field I
understand or the the the the field at
the school and so it rained and they
brought them into the building so it's
not like we need it for one night and
then they're not on the on the campus
they are they're on the school campus I
don't I don't think it's a field of the
school it was like an Airfield that they
were at and then no I thought it was the
school well here's part of what you'll
get we had one of the the moms and a
daughter reacting to this move and I
think they clarify because to your point
though Rachel why do you have these
illegals in this horrible place where
they have to then be moved because of
weather right why do you have a policy
that that allows them into the country
but you don't have a place for them but
then yeah and then in the first place
you build a shelter in a terrible place
so here's the here's the mom and the
daughter reacting to the move of this
principle on Thursday on Fox and Friends
I will be fine but it's also a day that
I could have spent learning and
especially with exams around the corner
I could have been been better pre for it
instead of was home and doing
assignments and not even interacting
with the teachers why does James Madison
or any other school for example has to
Bear the burden um of the city's migrant
crisis I mean Floyd benefit field is
vulnerable to all weather conditions so
what does that mean that my child's
school will be their shelter um this
winter the problem is the government
seems to prioritize uh migrant families
over their own uh law-abiding tax Bay
citizens I mean I feel for the migrant
families I really do but um this is
another example of our elected officials
not being in touch with the people I'm
asking the government I'm asking the
president I mean please look at what's
going on in our own neighborhoods in our
own
City you know it's
just deal with it it's going to happen
you're going to lose your schools you're
going to lose your city services you're
going to lose uh your tax dollars the
city Chicago mayor Brandon Johnson won't
commit to not raising taxes because of
the illegal immigrant crisis deal with
it this is you're saying welcome to
third world no I'm just telling you like
a 1 plus one is two you know this is how
it works if you have a southern border
that is open and you have a policy that
incentivizes illegal immigrants to come
and I'm not being um callous towards
that mother and child I'm saying it's
like you jump off a cliff you fall okay
this is what happens if it happens at
the southern border it's going to happen
here and There and Everywhere You
pretend like this is a problem while
pretending that's not a problem do you
know where it doesn't happen will it
doesn't happen in the shishi private
schools of the elite Democrats who are
who are most in support of this policy
it's going to Public Schools um that's
where they're they're having these these
these issues so I'm sorry um let's see
let's see them go to some of these
shishi schools here in on the Upper East
Side and and see if they will house the
migrants I'm just proud that there's
still a James Madison High School in New
York City you know take take the winds
where you can get them I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis